i can absolutely see how you do it does
it does your heading as a first year
undergraduate as a second year
undergraduate as a third year
undergraduate and as a professor of
physics it does my head in so
it's um yeah it's it's a very tricky
concept
so one symbol that's very important to
me is the symbol j and it represents a
part of a complex number and it has a
very special significance because to all
physicists and engineers j squared
equals -1
and
that
sounds already to be an extraordinary
kind of object it's something that has
only been appreciated for a few hundred
years in mathematics the idea that we
can find the square root of a negative
number and we call it uh naturally an
imaginary
number well yeah i can explain the the
conundrum of a square root of a negative
number if i take 0 and square it i get
0. if i take 1 and square it i get 1.
and if i do the same with the negative
numbers now minus one squared
unfortunately is plus one and minus two
squared unfortunately is plus four so
you can't get at the negative side of
the axis with a square
until you use j
no i'd call if i understand correctly
what sheamus calls j i would call that i
in that it's the square root of minus
one for me j would be something like a
current density so the difficulty here
is that we've got the so the same
letters that have been used in multiple
senses and actually that does make it
quite difficult for example for
undergraduate students to get get their
heads around some of these concepts when
we keep shopping and changing a long
time ago it was depicted by the greek
symbol iota
and i think that people have always
associated iota with either something
very small or something very very
abstract indeed
and over the years because i is used for
so many other things uh jay has become
the the
preferred symbol
we are certainly set in our ways in that
you won't get many physicists to sort of
go over to the dark side of the
engineers and start using j for example
but that's a question of the culture
you've built
you you you grow up in i guess as things
become more interdisciplinary we might
start to see a little bit more um
cohesion in terms of the
usage of symbols j is all about rotation
it's about things that go round and
round or that oscillate up and down in
some kind of
sinusoidal or smooth way and j has
particular significance
in what we call the complex plane
can you get your head around i know you
use it but can you get your head around
the idea of an imaginary number um
in truth no um it's a device it's only a
mathematical convenience it's a way to
help us to use the equations
to get a prediction although we can
mathematically represent it and
mathematically represented with i for
example we cannot observe it it's not an
observable quantity it's not a
physically observable quantity and the
output in the input are both real things
they're both measurable instantaneous
quantities like displacement and force
or voltage something we can measure
inside in the middle of this
mathematical process we use some numbers
that you can't measure you could never
measure an imaginary quantity and yet
they help us to make the right
prediction of what comes out
in terms of ii is a really really
important
concept really important number for um
for physicists does that but do you see
how that looks to people like you
understand it but can you imagine how
that looks to people like me
i can perfectly well imagine how it
looks and i distinctly remember
first encountering the concept of an
imaginary
number and there are some
superb papers written that in fact
discount the idea that we should ever
use j on the grounds that it conceals
some structure that we could explain by
another means and so yes this the the
way complex numbers and this these
mathematical quantities are linked into
these very fundamental theories of
physics in the physical world
means that
yes there are things that although we
can express them mathematically we
certainly have not got our heads
completely around but in actual fact
it's proven its value in engineering
it's taught in all undergraduate courses
probably from engineering courses from
the first year
and it simplifies all of our
calculations in dynamics